(clapping)
- Have a seat!
- Thank you, thank you for having me!
- Oh my gosh, you're so funny!
We haven't seen each other
since you were my manager.
- Yes!
- He was my manager at
my Christmas special.
- Kelly Clarkson Christmas special, yo!
(Kelly laughing)
- I was so nervous.
I told you that backstage but
I'm not an actor so I was...
And you're so funny, and I was so nervous.
I was so sweaty.
- You were amazing!
I honestly did the special to meet you
and you're just so nice and
so cool and it was like--
- I couldn't believe you said yes.
- And I actually got to reference...
We did a scene together where
I think I referenced "Walk Away".
- [Kelly] You did.
- I'm just having an argument
with you in character
as I'm just gonna
♪ Walk away ♪
or whatever it was but it
was so bad they cut it.
- No, it was so awesome
because it made me feel good
'cause I was like,
"Oh wait, no, he knows this song."
(Ken laughing)
He's actually like a fan.
'cause everybody always is like,
"Oh, I'm such a fan,"
and they don't know you.
- Right, right, right (laughing).
- They're like, "Yeah, that
one song, it was great."
(Ken laughing)
Yeah, but congrats though
you just turned 50, right?
- I just turned 50 years old.
(audience cheering)
- That's amazing!
- Thank you!
- Two questions.
- I know I don't look it, I get it,
they say black don't crack,
well, Asian don't raisin.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I've actually never heard that.
- Really, you've never heard that?
That's on my new album,
Asian Don't Raisin is
coming out whenever, so.
- I've really never heard of that.
- Really?
Okay.
- But it's true and I'm angry about it,
because I'm not Asian or black.
And I'm just starting to look old.
- You look amazing, what
are you talking about?
- I am three years away
from 40, man, tell me,
it gets better, right?
It gets cool, right?
40's gonna be awesome, right?
- You are,
♪ Forever young ♪
whatever.
You know what I mean?
(audience clapping)
You never age.
- Once you turn 50, though,
are you the guy on the
lawn yelling at children?
Are you that guy?
- Well.
- [Kelly] Does that happen?
- I'm more the guy who
just doesn't care anymore.
- Oh, that hit me about
16 (laughing).
- No, literally, you know
you don't care where...
I mean, I know I'm wearing this suit now,
I'm lookin' fly.
- Lookin' fly!
- But, you know you don't
care where everything I wear
is like Gap shirt, Gap jeans, Gap jacket.
- [Kelly] It's comfortable.
- I'm not even kidding,
this was literally what I wore to work.
I don't know if the camera
can get this right here.
- [Kelly] First of all, great point!
- Thank you.
These are Kirkland brand socks.
(audience clapping and laughing)
- Not a sponsor, just a fan?
- Not a sponsor, women's size six.
Just, it's the only thing
that lives and breathes
on my foot toes.
- On my foot toes.
- Yup.
- Well congrats on season
three of The Masked Singer.
I was telling you.
- Oh, thank you so much!
(audience clapping)
- My family, huge fans of the show,
they totally guess before y'all do.
(Ken laughing)
They're incredible at it.
So what's new this year?
- First of all, it is such an honor
to be a part of an amazing family show.
Families love it and it's
like, my kids love it,
Alexa and Zooey, they love it.
- What are their names?
- It's so fun to bring the
family together to watch it
and this season is just bigger and better.
The producers, God bless
them, they just find new ways
to reinvent themselves every year
but the talent pool is deeper,
there are just more surprising reveals.
It really has evolved.
The show has just gotten
better as its gone along
and I'm invested into it as a fan
even if I wasn't on the show.
It's like America's guessing
game and it's just super fun.
- I love a game so I'm in, yeah.
- [Ken] Yeah, absolutely.
- I love trying to guess.
I'm not as good.
My sister nails it every time.
- Really?
- Yes.
- You're looking at a guy
that's never got a guess
right in three years.
- I know, you say you're
the coolest judge.
- I'm the dumbest judge
on The Masked Singer.
(Kelly laughing)
- But you have another project
that's actually pretty amazing,
Women's Cancer Research Fund, right?
- Yes.
- So how did you get started in this?
(Kelly and audience clapping)
- Thank you, yes.
I'm hosting a benefit on February 27th
for the Breast Cancer Research Fund
and it's called An Unforgettable Night
and it is a fundraiser for
research for breast cancer.
My wife, she is a breast cancer survivor
(audience clapping)
and she's going on 11 years.
Yup, there she is right now.
It's an honor to work
with that organization
and we're actually
honoring Renee Zellweger
for her contributions to
breast cancer research.
It's an amazing night.
I was there last year and
the amount of money we raised
was just record amounts and everything,
it is wonderful that everybody,
we're all using our efforts to--
- [Kelly] Your spotlight, yeah.
- Yeah, the spotlight and
being a former physician,
just knowing where this
money goes and advances
in specific receptor therapy,
it can make all the side effects
from chemo very tolerable,
so there's a lot of excitement,
in the forefront of cancer therapy.
- And I know it affects you
personally 'cause your wife
but I feel like cancer
hits home with everyone.
If it's not directly, it's indirectly.
Everybody knows someone, unfortunately.
- Everyone knows someone
who either has cancer
or knows someone who has
been affected by cancer.
- It's important you're
doing these benefits.
It's important everyone is
stepping up and doing that.
- Yeah, it's important just
to remind ourselves that
we are all cut from the same cloth
and that if we can do whatever we can
to help and heal each
other, that's a good thing.
- Yeah, raise money,
alleviate things, yeah, I agree with you.
(audience clapping)
So what can people....
What can we do to help?
Like, how can people help?
- Well, you can go to the website.
I believe it's called wcrfcure.org
and I'll put it on my social media as well
to help contribute,
but just the fact that...
Thank you for letting me
even talk about it right now.
It's a big deal to me, so thank you.
- It's a big deal to us here, too.
We've actually had several stories
and several different
organizations on the show so far,
'cause it's important.
It's important to eradicate it.
It's important to get
there and get to a cure.
- Yes, absolutely, all
forms of cancer, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yes, absolutely.